ensemble ils savourent le goût sucré de
la victoire pas même troublé juste
heureux pour un coup d'essai ce fut un
coup de maître
le rap synthé médaille d'or maintenant
présenter un projet elle est meilleure
depuis la médaille
un petit goût différent oui très eu un
bon résultat non quand le verdict tombe
et que vous regardez à trois fois sur
site du concours agricole si c'est bien
la fameuse feuille à feuille
or alors vous vous dites que le pari est
gagné il y a trois ans il y avait là ni
alambic ni bouteille juste la volonté de
refaire les gestes des générations
d'avant une idée qui a germé en même
temps que les premiers chants d'absinthe
replanter autour de pontarlier nous
sommes en 2001 stéphane marc guay à
leurs agriculteurs démarre son odyssée à
la pioche
quinze ans plus tard la distillerie des
deux complices sur mille bouteilles
d'une recette maison et s'est fait une
petite place entre les légendes locales
guy et pernod un conte de fée verte à la
morale tout simple on essaye de
travailler produits de manière
authentique
on travaille avec nos propres plants on
essaye de distiller de manière très
régulière et comme le faisait
j'allais dire nos anciens donc au final
sapée on en est vraiment vraiment
satisfait
une médaille d'or qui vaut celle du
mérite celui d'avoir ouvert une
distillerie dans un secteur qui les a
presque tout vu disparaître au siècle
dernier alors chanté et modération bien
sûr